I wanted to be really successful but not
just to like get shoes I knew I wanted
to make money because I wanted to make a
difference listen to your gut and your
heart because no matter what any expert
tells you your wisdom inside needs to be
paramount when I was bartending I was
fully bartending like I wasn't talking
to myself about oh my god I should be
dancing right now or I should be working
on my coaching practice while I was
growing my personal coaching practice I
kept feeling conflicted because I didn't
want to just be one thing are you guys
here because you want to be mediocre
mediocre sucks does it not don't get
taken over by the world's definition of
success it's like everything that I've
learned and I've been able to do in my
business we never know what's going to
work
you should just engage an experience and
actually get your foot in the industry
that can inform whether or not you
should move ahead I have been this way
meaning goofy silly since I was very
very little you walk around your day and
you're like wow I have so many things to
do in like wait a minute this is all
awesome stuff to do she's an American
life coach motivational speaker author
and youtuber
she's the owner and creator Marie Forleo
international b-school and Marie TV
Forbes comm listed her website as one of
the top 100 websites for entrepreneurs
she's Marie Forleo and here her top ten
rules for success
you know my first gig out of college was
on Wall Street on the New York Stock
Exchange and
this is pre everything this is like just
out of college 21 years old and I knew
one of my drives I wanted to be really
successful but not just to like get
shoes I knew I wanted to make money
because I wanted to make a difference I
wanted to be able to take care of my
family I wanted to be able to contribute
to causes that I believe in and so I
knew in order to do that in my own mind
I was like well I want to make a lot of
money and make this stuff happen but
when I was on Wall Street even though so
many people that I worked with multi
multimillionaires I mean the money was
ridiculous
while they were financially rich they
were spiritually bankrupt and I felt
like there was a part of me that was
dying inside and I said this is not my
path I don't know what my path is but I
need to leave this because I feel sick
and so I think many people feel like
that you can find yourself and job and
job and job and you want to do a really
you want to do great work in the world
you're giving it your best that some
little voice inside is saying this isn't
me this isn't me and I kept having that
voice until finally I left the corporate
world and started my own business
listen to your gut and your heart
because no matter what any expert tells
you your wisdom inside needs to be
paramount it needs to always drive all
of your decisions even you know when I
was first starting out and I would pay
attention to people that absolutely knew
what they were doing they were
completely ethical they were smart they
were good teachers as well sometimes
their advice just didn't sit right with
me and if I wasn't as secure in my own
inner voice I might have gone down past
that wouldn't have been that great so I
think it's wonderful to get an education
it's wonderful to take in experiences
but never ever ever listen to anything
other than what is the true voice within
you and that takes practice when I was
bartending I was fully bartending like I
wasn't talking to myself about oh my god
I should be dancing right now or I
should be working on my coaching
practice I was just really into
bartending and when I was dancing I was
like you know being the best hip hop
teacher dancer I could possibly be when
I was being a coach same kind of thing
and I think that pract
of being fully engaged in the thing that
you're doing conserves a ton of energy
and that's what most people don't do
part of what was also challenging for me
when I was starting off as a coach was
recognizing the truth that I didn't just
want to be a coach I loved writing I
loved hip-hop
I loved dance I loved fitness there were
all these different things that I was
passionate about and while I was growing
my personal coaching practice I kept
feeling conflicted because I didn't want
to just be one thing as anyone ever felt
that way so I would listen to the voices
in my head which were like and basically
the voices in my head were so trained by
traditional wisdom and traditional
thoughts about you have to pick a niche
you have to narrow down you have to
choose one thing and be good for it
beyond be really good in it and that's
how you'll be known and when I realized
that that voice wasn't the voice I
should listen to that there was this
truth that I was this multi passionate
person and that living in the present
moment which Eckart teaches was all
about really listening to your own inner
guidance and being in the here and now
and not stressing so much up here that
really opened the door for me to say you
know what screw it I'm going to go take
dance classes I'm going to go learn
about this I'm going to do all these
different things and it that training to
be in the moment and to listen to my own
inner guidance allowed me to disconnect
from all the BS voices in my head that
were torturing me torturing me how would
you behave if you were the best in the
world at what you do how would that
change what time you wake up in the
morning how would that change the food
you put in your body how would that
change the people you hang out with how
you spend your time throughout the day
what websites you visit whether or not
you work from a schedule if you were
world class and the best in the world at
what you do how would your behavior
change it's a really interesting
question that I started asking myself a
few years ago and I will tell you it has
changed everything it's one of those
singular questions whether you put it on
your screensaver you
have a little reminder on your cell
phone you have it on the top of a
notebook I guarantee you if you start
looking at your world through this lens
it's going to shift everything now let
me ask you this just to back this up a
little bit more are you guys here
because you want to be mediocre mediocre
sucks does it not we want to be
world-class we want to be the best and
let me ask you this who's in charge of
you being the best in the world
yes can I hear an I am a little louder
one more Amen and it's not even a Sunday
okay good you had to give someone who's
recently graduating from our program a
piece of advice what would you say I
would say to learn and to execute on
your unique vision define success for
yourself figure out what that means to
you don't get taken over by the world's
definition of success or your families
or what your friends are doing or what
anyone says that equals success once you
can get clear on that vision then you
need to create a plan to make that come
to life and to prioritize I think one of
the biggest tragedies of our time is I
hear so many people from every walk of
life health coaches all over feeling so
overwhelmed and overworked and there's
so much that they can do that they feel
paralyzed well I don't know what to do
first or what how do I make all of this
happen and I think that we all need to
take a few steps back and start to get
clear on our own vision for success and
then actually prioritize making that
come to life because then it gives you
such clarity and such freedom and all of
that static and the overwhelm starts to
fall away what if I actually follow my
heart and I don't make a living at it oh
my
friends say you suck see I told you so
heck I'd actually talked about when he
was moving once his parents said really
you're going to do this again like
they've seen him as a failure for years
and then anyways but there's that always
that voice it's like yeah yeah yeah but
you might just really fail yeah and you
know I think all of us have that and
there's perhaps some of them like a myth
that many of us can think especially
when we're first starting out that
successful people don't have the voice
anymore that's total crap anyone that
you've ever seen anyone that I've
encountered and I've had the opportunity
to interview a lot of people and talk to
them no matter how successful how
accomplished how well-known they still
have those voices of self-doubt they
still get afraid they still question am
I going in the right direction what's
next for me and I think the more that we
can recognize that that voice of
basically you suck is universal and we
can disengage from that and actually
engage with what we want in our lives
the happier we're going to be and this
is the other thing none of us know it's
like everything that I've learned and
I've been able to do in my business we
never know what's going to work we treat
every single thing as an experiment
that's the only way that you learn I
think 99% of what each of us need to do
to learn and grow not only as business
people but also as human beings if we're
going to grow it means that we've never
done that before
it's going to be uncomfortable and to be
okay in that uncertainty and that
discomfort is where the juice of life
lives I really went into pursuing
different passions with eyes wide open
meaning knowing because my focus was
split I probably wouldn't be getting
very far in any of them but I made a
conscious choice that I just wanted to
experience them I wanted to understand
them from the inside out I spent so much
time thinking in my mind is this the
right choice for me is this the right
career for me should I try and build a
business around this and I said that's
such a dumb way to go around it like you
should just engage an experience and
actually get your foot in the industry
that can inform whether or not you
should move ahead about someone who's
stuck or struggling what would you tell
them stuck or struggling is is typically
someone who is more engaged in their
thoughts than actually taking acts
so it's a really interesting subtle
shift but if you catch yourself
complaining like oh I'm so stuck and
stop yeah write an email make a call
take a step and the more you actually do
that and catch yourself we actually
sorry this is me a DD my toes are
exactly that color awesome yes love it
then um but it is it's really a practice
of checking in with yourself you gotta
check yourself before you wreck yourself
like stop complaining stop talking
yourself in your head and do something I
have been this way meaning goofy silly
since I was very very little and when I
first started my coaching practice when
I was 23 I tried to be what I thought in
my mind was a businesswoman I had this
idea of like a power suit and some like
big old shoulder pads and I would speak
in a certain way and I remember trying
to do that and I felt horrible like I
felt so stunted it was like I had
writer's block I had speakers block I
just felt like I was in somebody else's
skin and it was so painful for me that I
was just like I can't do this but I
really want to do this thing I'm gonna
let go of my idea of who I think I
should be and talk about the fact up
from Jersey I don't use proper language
all the time I have kind of a weird
sense of humor I love zombies Smurfs all
kinds of things and what would happen if
I actually just express that and
something funny actually did happen is
not only did I find myself to be more
creative
I found myself more fulfilled and people
actually connected with me more I didn't
feel like I had to push myself out into
the world it was more like things
started to come to me and I didn't feel
like there was so much of a separation
between my workday and the rest of my
life which felt great for me a good life
is a couple things one being fully
present in each moment because I find
that when I am fully present like you
know you and I having this great
conversation our if I'm with Josh and
we're just hanging out it does not
matter what we're doing but I feel so
peaceful and content and like all is
well in the world even if there's
challenges I feel a sense of peace
and that's one component of it and I
think the other component for me of
living a good life is is having good
friends and having a lot of fun I think
anytime that I slip into taking things
too seriously you know like I know you
walk around your day and you're like wow
I have so many things to do I'm like
wait a minute
this is all awesome stuff to do and I
set my life up this way I better not
take it so seriously and have a little
fun and put on some music and dance when
that kind of thread of celebration and
irreverence and not taking things too
seriously that's what living a good life
feels like to me
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because you Lena asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll join
the discussion I'd also love to know
which of Maria's top ten rules meant the
most to you and the biggest impact leave
it in the comments and I'll join the
discussion and while I sing my personal
goals that hit 1 million subscribers on
this channel so anything that you can
think of to share the video tweet it out
of the playlist tell your friends about
it I'd really really really really
appreciate it thank you guys so much
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
the fact that when you're good at
whatever you're good at so for me I was
so passionate about spirituality and
personal development and all of the
tools that come in that toolbox but
recognizing you also have to know how to
run a business and being good at
something isn't the same thing as being
able to run a business doing that thing
and I recognized very quickly that I
needed to understand how to market and I
wanted to use these new online tools
specifically because I was so
embarrassed about my age because I was
so young that I wanted to use the
Internet which I did to mask my age and
I never lied but I got headshots done
that made me look much older than I was
and I put up a website and all of my
clients came to me through the internet
and if they didn't ask how old I was I
didn't tell them I just did the best
work I could but that key lesson about
even if you love something and even if
it's your passion you have to also get
passionate about entrepreneurship want
to make a living if you want to make a
living at it as a solo entrepreneur as a
business owner nothing will kill your
business faster than being lost in a
crowd of Sammys how many people here
ever feel like you look around and it's
like everybody's doing the same [ __ ] did
right do you feel like that everybody
starts copying each other and it all
starts to look the same and it all
starts to sound the same so positioning
is all about positioning yourself to be
vastly different this is probably one of
my favorite parts of this presentation
I'm going to teach you something that is
so damn good I promise if you do this
for your whole business and every
product or service you have you'll be
able to articulate very very clearly
exactly how you are different and more
importantly than articulating it it's
going to be a living breathing essence
of how you stand apart from everybody
else I feel like I love the process of
learning and discovering new things so
much and I love seeing other people win
so like learning these new ideas and new
skills that I never been exposed to
before and then being able to teach them
to other people and watch
the aha moments or the breakthroughs or
the progress happen for them
I love seeing other people win so that's
what kept driving me and I was like wow
if I could do this but five people I
could do this with like 20 people or a
hundred people or a thousand people then
it was really it was exciting